the red hat Pirates are some of the most
mysterious and powerful characters in
one piece and as Shanks is joining the
race to become pirate king we are
finally learning a ton of new stuff
about his Origins and true Powers so
here is the complete story of Shanks and
his crew starting with shanks's Hometown
in chapter 434 we learned that Shanks
was born in a town somewhere in the West
Blue and the only random fact that we
have about this place is that it makes
fine wine okay however he did not stay
there for long as only one year after
shanks's birth the former pirate king
Goldie Roger found Shanks in a treasure
chest after his legendary battle on God
Valley with the pirate rocks Deezer back
in one Piece Film red which actually
dropped a lot of new Canon information
about all of the red hair Pirates it is
heavily hinted that Shanks is from the
vigorland family which we only know
because it was specifically mentioned by
the leaders of the world government
during that film and while we know
nothing else about this mysterious
family quite yet the fact that they are
specifically mentioned by the five
Elders here means that the figure lands
are very likely a family of celestial
dragons well this makes sense because we
do know that there were Celestial
dragons present on God valley during the
battle between Roger and Roxy's abek and
it would also explain why Shanks is able
to get a private audition with the
gorosei but regardless of his true
family little baby Shanks is now a part
of the crew of the first pirate king and
he along with his childhood friend buggy
the clown become Apprentice pirates on
the crew at a very young age in fact
even before the age of 9 Roger already
gives Shanks the iconic straw hats and
by the time the chinx is 12 he is
fighting alongside the rest of the crew
as we see in their clashes against
Roger's former rival Shiki or against a
young Whitebeard not exactly the world's
greatest parenting I would say well
Shanks is 13 during that battle with
whitebeard's through and it was here
that shanks's faded rivalry with
Blackbeard first begins now after that
battle Shanks and buggy realized that
the young Blackbeard appears to not
sleep at night and while Shanks
initially thinks that this sounds
incredibly fun their conflict will come
to shape the future of the entire one
piece world but speaking of buggy these
two have a particularly long history and
friendship they fought many battles
together with Roger's crew Shanks was
the one who hilariously caused buggy to
accidentally eat his devil fruit and
Shanks even stayed behind with a sick
buggy when Roger and the rest of the
crew finally went to love tale both of
them cried together after Roger
disbanded the crew when Shanks was only
14 years old and while these two friends
eventually separated after Roger's
execution shank still knows how to get
under buggy skin as we see during Marine
forts when he tricks buggy with a
promise of a fake treasure and of course
this rivalry is bound to continue in the
current storyline because by some
strange twist of Fades they are both
currently Emperors of the sea okay so
after Roger's death we now move Beyond
shanks's Time with Roger at the age of
17 he sets out to find a crew and become
a great Captain himself now it is well
known that during his younger days
Shanks had legendary duels with the
strongest swordsman in the world dracul
Miha according to whitebeards these
duels were such powerful clashes that
they left the entire world desperate to
know who had won each single fight now
however these two have a very curious
relationship they were obviously Fierce
Rivals but after Shanks lost his arm
mihawk refused to continue fighting him
mihawk really seems to regret that his
most challenging rival can no longer use
his stronger swords arm despite this
though mihawk still shows shang's
tremendous respect as he refuses to
fight against him during the war at
Marine Forts and even more than that
mihawk is the one who brought Luffy's
very first bouncy poster two Shanks in
chapter 96 so it is very light likely
that he actually holds shanks's Weaver
card as how else would he just find The
elusive red hair Pirates so it does look
like Shanks and mihawk have indeed
become very close friends over time and
even though both mihawk and bhagi
declined joining the red hat Pirates
Shanks did end up Gathering a truly
impressive crew after Roger's execution
most of which actually appear in the
very first chapter of the story this
core group of members are known as the
redhead pirate Executives starting off
with Ben Beckman the Vice Captain who
surprisingly is a serious womanizer a
gun specialist and the smartest
character from the entire East blue
similar to Rayleigh or Zorro it is said
that he is not too far away in power
from his captain he's even strong enough
to make an admiral like Kizer who
hesitates and it is also suggested that
he is the one who took the arm from
Eustis kits next up quite unsurprisingly
lucky Roo is the redhead Pirates cook
because we fittingly almost never see
him without a slab of meat or a drink
this fun-loving mountain of a man fights
with a gun and also by Rolling his
massive body into a bowl to smash into
opponents interestingly enough he's also
the very first person to actually kill
somebody in the story aside from Roger's
executioners along with Ben Beckman and
lucky Roo usop's long-lost father yasob
always appears whenever shank's crew
shows up somewhere and much of what we
love about usob seems to be also true
about his father they're both Jokers who
love to encourage the crew to have fun
although yasop is clearly sweating about
meeting his son after abandoning him at
a young age naturally yasap is also a
god-level sniper and Shanks recruited
him specifically because it is said that
he never misses his targets and while we
know much less about the rest of the
crew we did learn a little bit more
about the main officers from the booklet
that was handed out alongside the movie
film Reds for example lime juice here
apparently fights with his staff charged
with electricity and likes to jump
around in the air similar to Sanji with
his electricity theme he could possibly
clash with nami one day as well next we
have the duo bunk punch and monster who
are each listed as officers even though
they are fighting as a team this pair
are the musician of the crew and
possibly even inspired Luffy to have a
musician on his own crew as well bunk
punch fights by charging up devastating
punches while monster takes care of the
weaker enemies who try to stop his
partner next building snake is the
Navigator of the crew and just like Nami
he Sports some very serious ink he
fights with two swords that he
apparently juggles in the air and he
also has a signature stomp kick that he
uses to finish enemies and then we have
hongo the doctor of the red hat Pirates
which well all the other crew members
love to party he seems to be one of the
more serious members he was also the one
who after wano reminded chance that
Luffy's Ally bartolomeo was causing
problems in one of their territories and
it was actually this reminder that
convinced Chang's to avoid meeting Lou
just yet naturally hongo has incredible
knowledge of medicine but is
surprisingly knowledgeable about weapons
as well as he said to be able to take
apart any weapon instantly and while
holding Gap here looks really ferocious
he apparently has a quite kind
personality and is even timid when not
in battle however when he does fight he
uses this power drawer blast to wreck
enemies from a distance I can only
imagine him and Frankie shooting laser
beams at each other from a distance and
we're also told that he can even use
paralysis to take out opponents then we
have also Rockstar and while he has only
joined the red hat Pirates more recently
he seems to be a trusted messenger who
is tasked with communicating with other
pirate captains he's a prideful man who
fights with a sword and seems to be able
to use it like a drill and in general we
can also assume that all of them are
ridiculously strong with the ability to
use both Armament and observation hockey
as even the Marines acknowledge that the
red hat Pirates are an equally balanced
fighting force although though it has to
be said that no one in shanks's crew has
eaten a devil fruit which makes me
wonder do they just really like to swim
or could it be that Shanks knows a
secret condition of getting to a love
tale that requires not having a devil
fruit whatever the answer is the red hat
Pirates are of course a true Powerhouse
crew and we will of course discuss
everything we know about shanks's
ridiculous Powers later on in this video
however there is one other member of
shanks's family that we have yet to
discuss when Shanks is 20 years old he
finds a baby girl in a treasure chest
this is of course utta and while this
was shown to us explicitly in one Piece
Film red we actually don't really know
if these childhood events of the movie
are an actual part of the Canon
storyline what we do know is that UTA
seems to appear in a single panel here
in chapter 1055 next to a baby Luffy
momot Yori which seems to make her
backstory Canon and so maybe because
Shanks was also adopted in the very same
way he takes in utta as part of his crew
Lucha grew up with the red hat Pirates
and also befriended a young Luffy with
the two forming atheist rivalry and
friendship when Shanks visits the Goa
Kingdom Luffy's Hometown and while utta
displayed her crazy devil fruit power in
film Reds none of the other red hair
pirate officers have their own devil
fruits however they did have an interest
in one particular fruit right before we
meet them in chapter 1 they had just
stolen the mythical sun god Nika fruit
from a world government ship now what is
unclear is if Shanks knew the true
powers of this fruit and its awakened
form or if he just stole it by random
chance but come on do we really believe
that this was a coincidence and if this
was actually intentional then was he
trying to find the next Joy boy and if
so who did he have in mind to eat that
fruit these questions make me really
wonder what exactly Roger's last words
were to Shanks that made him cry so much
could he have told Shanks to find his
fruit and to guide the next Joy boy to
find the one piece I mean it is
certainly possible especially because
suspiciously enough many former Raja
pirate members are scattered along the
path to love tail seemingly ready to
help Luffy whenever the time arrived
like crocus or Rayleigh but again we
have to ask was this really to help
Luffy or does Shanks have his own
motivations for wanting Luffy to succeed
and all of that has happened to Shanks
before we even started chapter one it is
at the start of the story when we first
meet a 27 year old Shanks and the crew
in the Goa Kingdom Luffy's Hometown and
here Shanks inspires Luffy to become
pirate king he even sacrifices his good
arm to protect Luffy and gives him the
straw hat before he leaves the island
we've actually only recently learned
that Shanks already had a bounty of over
1 billion berries in chapter one an
insane amount that tells us that Shanks
was already a world famous pirate just
12 years after Roger's execution however
unfortunately after this chapter we
barely ever get to see Shanks in actual
action 10 years after first meeting fee
in chapter 96 Shanks is 37 years old now
and we see him throw a party after
mihawk brings him Luffy's first Bounty
poster next we see him twice trying to
warn Whitebeard about Blackbeard once
via messenger and once in person and
when the two Emperors meet both Shanks
and whitebeards talk about scars that
ache because of blackbeards hinting at
his importance for the future this is by
the way also the very first time that we
hear about hockey and see what the power
of conquerors haki can actually do but
this is of course nothing compared to
shanks's biggest hockey feat that we
will discuss a little bit later in the
video and while all of these examples
are kind of brief shang's first major
involvement after chapter one comes
during the war at Marine forts first he
stops the strongest creature in the sea
kaido from coming to the battle in the
first place and then Shanks does this
stopping the rampaging Akainu who even
Whitebeard couldn't keep down with
shanks's arrival the war at Marine for
it immediately ends as not even
Blackbeard or the fleet Admiral sengoku
are willing to fight the red hair pirate
crew in fact we learned that Shanks has
earned great respect from sengoku
something that no other pirate has done
since whitebeards and boy does he
deserve it as we see Shanks respectfully
burying both Ace and Whitebeard after
the war he's not just a badass but he's
a classy dude as well now if you're an
anime only Watcher you might not know
that it is possible that Shanks is
actually married and has a kid and no
I'm not talking about Utah while this
isn't officially confirmed there are a
few cover pages from the manga that show
Shanks at a wedding and Makino this bar
keeper from chapter one who Shanks was
kind of fond of with a wedding ring and
a baby if this is true it seems that
Shanks has been doing a lot more than
just sitting around and drinking booze
if you know what I mean now after Marine
Ford we don't see him again in the main
story until chapter 903 when he's
reacting to Luffy's bounty after whole
cake Islands during this appearance the
now 39 year old Changs claims that Luffy
is still not quite ready to meet him
which makes me think that he is waiting
for Luffy to awaken the Nika fruit and
become joyful just another clue here
that he did really know what that fruit
was when he stole it however fortunately
we didn't have to wait too long until
his next appearance because we actually
see him again just four chapters later
doing something that no one would have
expected he had a private conversation
with the gurosei themselves and I see
that is still unexplained Shanks went to
discuss a certain pirate with the five
Elders who are for some reason
completely comfortable being in the very
same room with Shanks and while we don't
know who he is actually talking about
here it is likely either Blackbeard or
Luffy and it does make me wonder if he
was warning them that Luffy could soon
be Awakening his devil fruits now you
might be wondering why would Shanks tell
them about this but there is just so
much that we don't know about shanks's
past and his motivations remember that
Chang's likely comes from the figure
land family who could be Celestial
dragons this could explain how he is
able to meet with the godose in the
first place and if that wasn't strange
enough yet in the very next chapter that
gurose are discussing a great cleansing
for the world so what did Shanks tell
them that led them to that conclusion so
many questions after just that one scene
and things get even more intense after
wano during the festivities following
the victory over kaido Shanks arrives
and chases away the forest logia fruit
user Admiral green ball with a
conquerors hockey Blast from miles away
a truly never before seen and
Unthinkable feat which chose us just how
ridiculous strong the yonko is and yet
this appearance means so much more for
the story because because it finally
seems like Shanks is now ready to
acknowledge Luffy as a great pirate and
while he doesn't want to meet Luffy
quite yet after he sees Luffy's awakened
form on a bouncy poster he decides it is
now time to go claim the one piece for
himself in fact in chapter 1076 we see
Shanks in elbaf the Land of the Giants
about to confront Luffy's rival used as
kids and in order to do that you need
the four Road Pony glyphs which are
unbreakable Stones created during the
void Century in wano the three that we
know of so far are in zo wano and whole
cake Island all of which Luffy has
already found and it is wildly
speculated that the last missing one is
in elbaf exactly where we currently find
Shanks and so if Shanks wants to find
the one piece he can either sail around
and find the road poneglyphs himself or
just like Blackbeard in typical pirate
fashion he can steal the two that kit
has from wano and whole kick Islands
leaving him with just one more to find
if he already has the one in elbaf
assuming of course that he has someone
who can read them or he can just kidnap
someone who can but we do have to ask
why is Shanks only doing all of this now
if he really wanted to he should have
known where at least three of the pony
glyphs were and collected them years ago
because he found them all when sailing
with Roger so was Shanks waiting because
he needed Luffy to awaken his fruit and
become Joy boy we just don't know right
now but there are at least three
possibilities for shanks's future going
forwards first he could be the one
guiding Luffy to the one piece so that
Luffy can change the world for the
better this is the shanks is a good guy
version and how many of us have viewed
him for the entire story so far then
there's also of course the shanks is
secretly a villain Theory which has had
a lot of evidence such as his meeting
with the gorosei it is possible that
Shanks has been working with the gorosei
or emu all along as they try to erase
the threat of Joy boy and the one piece
forever however the third possibility is
that Shanks is just using Luffy for his
own personal goals as we've already
described Shanks is only acting now that
joyboy has awakened so it's possible
that it is a requirement to use the one
piece and now that Joy boy is here
Shanks is moving forward with his own
plans and if either of the last two are
the case then the red hat Pirates could
be a huge obstacle for the straw hats to
overcome at some point soon you see
Shanks is undeniably powerful with a
bouncy of over 4 billion berries the
highest active one in the story so far
even kaido consider Chang's to be one of
the handful of people who could actually
do you know that Chang's fights with one
of the Supreme great blades and he has
the strongest hockey feeds in the entire
story so far and he's even known as the
killer of observation haki blocking out
future side users such as Luffy and
katakuri we also recently learned that
she commands a large Fleet of strong
Pirates as well just like Whitebeard
tits aside from his Fleet he also has
numerous strong allies around the world
including it seems the Giants of elbeth
who are said to be the strongest
fighting force in the entire world so
when the time comes for Luffy to finally
meet Shanks it could be a joyous reunion
with lots of food and drinks or it could
also be a terrible battle and Luffy's
most difficult test yet but let's assume
that Shanks is the good guy and he truly
wants to help Luffy find the one piece
if this were the case it brings up a
really interesting question that takes
us all the way back to chapter one why
didn't chengs let Luffy join his crew
surely the red hat Pirates could have
taught Luffy so much and helped him
uncover the secrets of his legendary
devil fruits well if you want to know
all about what might have happened if
Luffy had joined shanks's crew you can
watch that video right here thanks for
watching